in Washington the brain trusts in the
Republican and Democrat parties are busy
planning their strategies for the
midterm elections in November
tonight correspondent Peter Doocy on
Capitol Hill looks at those messages the
parties are trying to convey the roadmap
that's proven successful for Republicans
and Senate primaries so far trash-talked
the incumbent Democrat for not helping
President Trump the walls being built
what the hell is a senator who will work
with President Trump Ohio expect to see
GOP candidates everywhere start touting
tax reform regulatory roll backs and the
flood of conservative judges to court
rooms if you look at the Supreme Court
nomination our judges right now are
filling the the federal courts making
good decisions based on the Constitution
not trying to be activist judges the
2018 strategy for some Senate hopefuls
also mimics Trump's anti-establishment
approach just look at Josh Holley trying
to unseat Democratic Senator Claire
McCaskill in Missouri they're furious
that DC has feathered its own nests that
people like Claire McCaskill have voted
in ways that benefit them and there's
special interest donors but Democrats
don't think Republicans can claim the
outside the beltway approach anymore
after what they call controversies
involving leaders of the EPA HUD and OMB
President Trump has become the swamp
their plan to win control of Congress is
called a better deal and tries to
diminish the crown jewel of the
Republican resume tax reform now the
rising gas prices will is one economist
put it roughly cancel out the 2018
consumption boost from tax cuts the
president's name is also being used to
try to motivate base voters the best
thing we can do
stop the the worst part about the Trump
agenda is to win the 2018 elections but
in States Trump just won Democrats can't
all run against him which means the
party isn't totally united in West
Virginia people like Donald Trump and
like Joe Manchin and you know what we
can work very well together that goes to
show you as strategies are being crafted
even the lawmakers considered the most
vulnerable are not all on board with the
messages their national leaders are
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
to promote Bret Peter Doocy on the hill
tonight Peter thanks